[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is my good friend george camel welcome
to the show george christie this is so
fun this is my first time co-hosting
with you and anyone but dave which i
consider this a big honor i'm so excited
i'm so excited
george and i are taking your calls about
money as always about time management
because you all know i'm going to kick
about that right now with my new book
take back your time but we're here for
you so maybe you have a question about
business leadership or just need some
advice
in what decision to make really in any
area of your life we're here for you
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five george and i are
hosting together all day today
and george this is your first time
hosting with me on fun friday what do i
need to know here's what's great
friday's just a little bit more casual
everybody's excited about the weekend
everybody's excited about their fun
plans so maybe you want to talk about
that i don't know i don't know what to
do personally i don't know if anyone
else cares about my plans but this is
big news for me as a millennial okay
trader joe's just opened 15 minutes
north of our headquarters okay and that
is a big deal for me and my family
christy well i'm so happy that we could
announce that that is this is fake news
i'm excited for you excited for you
people are cheering in the lobby this is
great what about you
uh i am actually gonna be a bridesmaid
and one of my very best friends wedding
this weekend and so it's gonna be a lot
of fun we kick it off this evening as
soon as i leave here this afternoon
actually we're going to the rehearsal
dinner and all that good stuff so if you
want to give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five
george and i are here to answer your
calls george i want to kick it off while
we're waiting for the calls to come in
and i want you to talk about because
i've heard the announcements in our
staff meeting i'm sure you've talked
about it on the ramsay show but i want
to hear from you directly
about your new show the fine print and
i've heard you talk a little bit kind of
in some meetings
about the
one of your hearts to help people
especially in the area of money i've
heard you say
i don't just want to put the cookies on
the bottom shelf i want to put them on
the floor i want to help people
understand
everything they need to know in really
simple terms and i'll tell you george
personally right now i am in seminary
and i'm reading these textbooks where i
don't understand nine out of ten words
in a sentence i have to look them up i
appreciate someone that has the heart of
a teacher to speak human language that
someone can understand and the finance
industry is one of those where it can be
intimidating it can be overwhelming
there are lots of big words there's lots
of legal fine print and you are going
right into the space to give hope to
people and help them understand what's
going on talk a little bit about your
heart behind it because i'm so excited
to see this for you yes you nailed it
christy and the and the reason i'm so
excited about this is exactly what
you're talking about there's so much
noise out there there's social media and
the headlines and you're broke
brother-in-law and my dad said to to get
the fha loan because the housing
market's hot and there's just so many
voices in your head and you can get so
overwhelmed which you talk about this
all the time
that you're just paralyzed by all the
indecision and you do nothing yeah you
don't know who to trust the wrong thing
exactly there's so much noise out there
i mean i'm on i'm i'm consuming a lot of
tick tock these days let me tell you
everyone is an expert on tick tock and
they're 16 year olds telling you to buy
into this cryptocurrency over here and
i'm going oh dear lord someone help
these people yeah and then we go oh
that's what we get to do every single
day and so what this podcast is
attempting to do
is really
show people the hidden truths that are
keeping them broke and we want to do
that in a fun narrative storytelling way
in a way that we've never really done it
before at ramsay so this is short form
30 minutes or less and it's a crafted
podcast this is really made for people
who love podcasts right the podcast
nerds out there and so we're talking to
experts we're hearing from real life
people we're hearing from ramsay
personalities and we're really digging
in with facts and research and stats and
empathy and humor to help people change
their paradigms yeah to then change
their decisions to change their habits
because we know that when you do that
you can change your life yeah well i
love hearing you talk about this because
it's so needed and it's one of those
things that i think that people do not
understand
that the vast majority of people out
there the vast majority of companies out
there that are giving financial advice
have an agenda
right if you're learning how to manage
your money from the credit card
companies
they have an agenda they're not looking
out for your best interest they're
looking out for their bottom line and
the big buildings that they're coming up
with these marketing strategies in and
so you know i remember back in the day
when i would uh you know teach on money
and travel and speak on money with
rachel cruz and we would travel and
speak to college students and i would
just tell them listen these credit card
companies are not trying to help you out
out of the goodness of their sweet
little hearts they have an agenda and
and so many even tax filing companies
often even insurance companies there's a
lot uh the vast majority really of these
companies have an agenda that is going
to affect them making money off of your
financial decisions and if we don't
realize that then we're going to think
oh well gosh they're here to help me so
i need to get this credit card because
they really want to help me out no they
don't no no they don't they don't want
to help you out they want to make money
off of the interest that you're going to
accrue from your spending and so what's
so great about you george and all of us
here at ramsey solutions
is that you don't have an agenda other
than to help them you're not making
money off of them getting credit cards
or getting a certain insurance we are in
the business of helping you we are in
the business of seeing you win when you
guys call us and you tell us you're
debt-free that is how we win that is
success to us and so i just love that
you're going into this space you've got
some podcast episodes that are out now i
love this one uh the first two here out
now how turbo tax is screwing you
from example yeah prime example of what
i was just talking about and the true
cost of credit card rewards
another great that's a huge one chris
that's what i'm talking about people
just love those rewards
they really do it's it's gamified and we
just get sucked into the game like ooh
but i could get a pair of jeans i could
get 200 cash back if i spend 30 000
people people people let's do some basic
third grade math it's hard
common core okay it's very difficult
these days it really is i hear all about
that listen you guys uh listen to
the fine print with george campbell
wherever you listen to podcasts this is
going to help you see
what's going on behind the scenes that
is affecting your financial decisions
and it's really those things like george
said that are keeping you
broke we don't want you to be broke we
want you to build wealth we want you to
be debt free we want you to have control
of your money everything we teach you
and every answer we give you
is for you
for you to have more money
more control more power more options and
a better future that is the driving
force behind every one of our principles
every one of our baby steps every one of
our books every single thing that we do
is for you to win
that's the why and i just love how
you're doing this george i love how
you're doing this on the fine print and
everything that you're doing you guys
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five
we'll be taking your calls george and i
are here for you on fun friday all right
george give us uh before we go to break
give us a teaser of what is something we
need to know
about one of these first two episodes
the turbo tax is screwing you and the
true cost of credit cards rewards give
us a teaser of what what's included
i'll give you the hook so the first one
on turbo tax i talked to dave and we go
through this like 200 page keynote that
they had for their shareholders who they
are obligated to guess what not to the
user not to the customer but to their
shareholders so we unpack how they're
actually coming to get you with debt
later on and credit card rewards of
course we know christy you're not gonna
get to wealth by using that credit card
and swiping away so we unpack so many
facts i talked to an ex-capital one
insider who really breaks down how
they're getting you so go subscribe to
the fine print listen to the first three
episodes it's a good time man
just the information
can set you free you don't even realize
how that is holding you back and
georgia's going to show you the fine
print wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm chrissy wright joining me today is
my good friend
george camel and we are taking your
calls about money life business
time management
you name it we're here for you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you try to call during the week and
you have trouble getting in fridays are
good because sometimes people are a
little distracted george it's fun friday
they're getting ready for the weekend
but hey we're here for you we're ready
to answer your questions give us a call
triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're gonna go to
cliff in indianapolis in indiana hey
cliff how are you
i'm good happy friday happy friday cliff
what's going on how can george and i
help
well i had a question regarding the
envelope system okay um
instead of using a physical envelope and
putting cash into it
is it okay to use a reloadable gift card
that you put money onto
and use that as the envelope
well this is an interesting question
cliff i've actually never heard this ask
but i first want to ask you why you want
to i'm just curious
well um
so our local
uh marching band um one of their
fundraisers is using as a gift card
program
so
i can purchase gift cards and
get reliable gift cards and each time i
put money on it the band earns
money to pay off band fees
so i actually paid off my sun ban fees
just by
purchasing gas and groceries with gift
cards interesting
well let me tell you some information
about gift cards and then i'm gonna let
george jump in on this one okay because
this is interesting this is a little
different a little weird which is why i
like it cliff we like weird especially
on fridays i like weird questions i do
okay first first thing you need to know
when you use a card
credit card debit card gift card any
kind of card
your brain does not register that as any
type of significant
pain
sacrifice
loss okay research shows this
when you use cash and you actually hand
over dollar bills your brain research
shows that with through mri imaging your
brain registers that as physical pain we
want you to feel a little pain when you
let go of your money because we want you
to know that it's happening it's the
exact opposite effect of when you uh i
was teaching uh dave about this couple
weeks ago george and cliff about add to
cart sometimes you just add things to
cart because it feels good you don't
really feel the pain of that when you
hit submit
a submit order or you swipe a card you
don't feel it which becomes a problem in
spending because you you spend more than
you realize so that's one thing you need
to know about swiping a card you're not
going to
feel that transaction as much
emotionally as we want you to and you
might be tempted to spend more
the second thing you need to know about
gift cards is 50 of them are never used
50 of gift cards
are never cashed in so
companies love selling gift cards
because they have a massive project
profit margin on them people lose them
and you've probably done it cliff i've
done it i'm guilty of it i've got gift
cards in my desk at home right now that
i haven't used so i i i camp our answer
and that information
and this is kind of like what we were
talking about earlier george where we
were talking about you're not going to
get rich off credit card points oh cash
back cash back we're not in this to play
the game cliff so what i would recommend
here's what i would recommend with that
in mind about we spend more when we
swipe a card we don't use gift cards and
we lose them and we forget their actual
real money with a value what i would
recommend you do if i were you
is i would stick to the plan stick to
the baby steps stick to the cash
envelope system and then if you just
want to give
out of your tithe out of your giving
because you just want to bless your
son's school out of your giving to be
able to pay for their banned things then
do that then it's all kept separate it's
all clean and it's going to keep you on
track because i'm just afraid that
that's going to become a slippery slope
where you're swiping right and left
you're losing cards having trouble
keeping up with your your budget and i
don't want you to get i don't want you
to get caught up in that george what
would you what would you say to that
yeah i love that mentality and i'm
assuming these are like reloadable debit
cards i don't i don't know the exact uh
parameters of this but like you're
saying christy there's this element of
if you want to help out you know pay
down the ban fees you can do that with
real money too and you don't have to
hope that you're you know five dollars
out of a hundred went to the band i
would just budget for this as a giving
item yeah right and just go hey what if
i could give 20 bucks a month to help
them pay this down because it's
something i'm passionate about so cliff
i love your heart behind this i want to
call that out that that's so cool that
you want to be generous i just think
logically there's a better way to be
generous than by using the gift cards
yeah so you know you can use a debit
card you can do the cash envelope system
whatever you're gonna do is gonna be
best for you so choose the one that's
actually gonna work that you stick to
and then make this a part of your uh
giving as part of a line item so that
you can help the the band out let's
let's talk about this though really
quickly george because i think this
brings up an interesting point that's
actually bigger than gift cards
and it kind of ties back to what we were
saying at the beginning of the hour of
this idea of credit card rewards
when we get distracted
on our path to managing our money on our
path to building wealth when we get
distracted by the games
games being credit card rewards gift
cards incentives if you you know buy a
pair of shoes someone else gets a pair
of shoes oh that's good and fine and
well but if we begin to make purchasing
decisions based on it for example i'm
going to buy some shoes because
someone's going to get shoes
we can get really distracted by the game
and lose sight of what our money is
doing and who's actually in control and
i think the psychology of that is really
fascinating because
you know dave and i were hosting earlier
this week and you'll have people call
sometimes and say well
um mathematically xyz of the baby steps
and they've got some criticisms or some
pushback and the reality is that if we
were if we were doing math we would have
never got ourselves in debt in the first
place it's it's more about
focus it's more about momentum than it
is about math and so even if yes you
could earn two free dollars for your
son's band in this example cliff or or
credit card points or get a pair of
jeans or get cash back
we're not doing it for the game and the
game actually will distract you from
what you're trying to do which is get
out of debt and build wealth and and i
know you see this george when you talk
to people because when you get questions
it's often these type of questions where
they're asking about ancillary
uh i'll call them carrots you know like
in in email marketing like you give
someone a carrot for their email address
it's kind of like they're holding out
these carrots like do you want this do
you want this free pair of jeans do you
want this
and when we get distracted by the
carrots when we get distracted by these
you know uh incentives
we lose track of what we're trying to do
and we can actually make bad decisions a
little at a time and not realize that oh
yeah and when you're talking about you
know the school making this whole thing
happen of course they're going to say
hey get gift cards because then it makes
it about you right instead of about hey
can we we need money to pay down the
band fees right and they're holding out
the offering it played it feels a little
bit different when it says hey buy some
gift cards and you'll help us out at the
same time right and so it kind of makes
you feel like wow i can i can help out
and i can kind of get what i want too
right right oh i've done that before
when you there's a buy one get when you
go well i'm really getting it for a gift
for a friend but hey i get something out
of this too right so this gamification
is all over the place we're seeing it
with cryptocurrency we're seeing with
credit card rewards we're seeing with
everything out there because there is a
psychology to it where you say christy
but you don't understand i can beat the
game and that's exactly what they want
you to think right
like perfect they're going to play this
game for the rest of their life and
think they're winning right and the
interesting thing is let's look at the
fruit of that because you are in debt
barely getting by on your bills and they
are in multi-billion dollar buildings
coming up with strategies winning here
right it's not y'all
we're not the ones winning when we're
playing these games that they come up
with here here's here's a good just like
here's a good tip okay
if they came up with a game
it's because they're gonna win it
they didn't come up with a game they're
gonna lose
they came up with a game that they're
gonna win so if you're playing someone
else's game
you're most likely going to be the one
losing in that scenario whether it's
credit card rewards
airline miles
even gift cards and it's not a bad thing
but but like the the principal here
cliff and for all of you
is keep it clean and separate you can it
doesn't mean we're saying oh don't
support your son's band oh yeah no just
give
when we my son started school a couple
weeks ago and the teacher had like a
wish list on amazon and so that was
super fun i knew what she needed here's
all the things i was able to go on
amazon select some items purchase them
and just bring them on the first day and
be like hey just we just want to donate
these to the class it wasn't fundraisers
are not bad y'all they're not bad at all
but when they distract you from your
financial goals and they lead you to
spend more than you would normally spend
then that's where it becomes a problem
so because it can be a slippery slope
keep it clean and separate
give and be generous we always teach you
guys to give and be generous and and you
can do that whether it's through your
school through your church whatever you
want to do but that's going to keep you
focused on your financial goals and then
you've got a line item for giving and
you've got a line item for groceries and
you've got a line item for everything
else and it's going to keep you on track
which is what you need when you've got
the whole world pulling at you telling
you to you know buy this and do this no
no we're gonna stay focused on the goal
get out of debt and build wealth and the
best way to do this with the baby steps
and the cash system it's a great
question cliff thank you for calling
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm christy wright george campbell and i
are hosting the ramsay show for you
today and we are taking your calls
triple eight eight two five
five two two five so if you have a
question give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five and i'm so excited
george because in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage are
giovanni and mariah how are you guys
good christy hi george hey hey okay guys
you are debt free where you
tell us the story how much did you pay
off uh we paid off
just over seventy eight thousand
seventy eight in eleven months oh
well no joke okay what's your range of
income during that time
uh
our total was 119 thousand four hundred
and fifty dollars
wow all right to the penny okay uh where
you guys from we're from wilmington
north carolina awesome i love it
okay so what do you guys do for a living
so i work in uh human resources at a
optical fiber company okay
and i work for north carolina state
highway patrol awesome cool how long
have you guys been married
just over two years wow okay so you got
married a couple years ago
what happened 11 months ago
so it all started um it was actually we
had just gotten back from a honeymoon in
march of 2020
and it was when the whole student loan
you know was going zero interest with
the covid and i was one night i was
looking over my loan bill still
and he walked in and he was you know
like oh you've graduated since 2012 how
much have you
paid down
and i was like you know i really don't
know i feel like it's grown
so it did grow
and it kind of forced us to really look
at it
and right then and there we were like
we're gonna hit this out we're gonna do
it so gotcha what what kind of uh so was
it just the student loan or was it other
debt as well yep so it was my student
loan was the majority of it um and then
we had some credit card loans which were
also mine and then we had a car loan um
27 000 the car loan credit cards about 6
500. gotcha okay so
you realize your student loan is growing
even though you were paying on it yeah
wow that must have been a moment where
you're going something has to change
yeah it was pretty defeating but
it kind of was a pivotal moment for us
gotcha so i'm curious the way that you
said that is interesting mariah you said
you know he asked how much the loan was
had you guys not really put your money
together yet or communicated about money
at this point no not really at that
point now gotcha okay so so what was the
light bulb moment what'd you guys decide
to do
well her cousin haley um i guess had
mentioned dave ramsey to her um in
passing pretty casual i didn't really
know a lot about him i knew nothing
about him yeah
you're like we just need some help yeah
i talked to my buddy
and i know it's probably weird to talk
to your friends about financial stuff
but he had mentioned that him and his
wife had done financial peace university
they became debt free
and kind of gave us the financial peace
cds and all that we
listened to them
dave talking about uh
gazelle mentality um
there's no looking back after that no
looking back
just hit it hard so we just jumped in um
so it got you fired up yeah all right
what did that look like for you guys
what were the things you did the changes
the sacrifices you had to make in order
to do this in 11 months yeah
they say rice and beans beans and rice
um kind of that you know i started
cooking from home um
just you know we stopped going out to
eat we started focusing on like hey do
we really need this
you know not spending so much on
frivolous things and knew that if we put
our heads down we could make it work
stop eating out yeah and she says rice
and beans beans and rice that first meal
i think she forgot the rice because it
was literally all beans
we're taking an extra step
we gotta tell people you can season it
too
don't forget about spices wow i love
that and i was talking to you guys in
the lobby yesterday and i was just super
inspired by your story and i know uh
giovanni you made some sacrifices
because you told me you like you like
toys yes and so that must have been hard
for you to say you know what uh i'm not
gonna do this at least for 11 months
we're going to go hard and get rid of
this thing absolutely what was the
hardest part for you guys
it wasn't always easy
and just saying no to a lot of things
you know and every other week when we
got paid we'd say you know get the book
our budget book and we'd sit down and
you know
there were times where you know i was
crying and i was like this really stinks
you know this is so hard but
i think the journey
was the hard part for me i only get paid
once a month um
i don't get paid weekly or bi-weekly um
so every month
it was twice we sat down
i would come home get the book
we would sit down and budgeting that
that's honestly the key and working
together yeah if you don't work together
there's no teamwork it will not work
yeah so so tell me after you guys
decided to get on board follow the baby
steps all that do y'all now have your
money together working as a team
communicating all that sounds like
absolutely absolutely yeah i'm curious
is this did this impact your marriage i
mean it's the money stuff aside do you
feel like wow we grew together as a
couple because of this i think it's made
us stronger yeah we know that we can do
anything if we put our minds to it and
just work together yeah you know and one
of us is struggling with staying
motivated the other one you know come on
we can do this that's you know and i
think that's that's key yeah so it was
hard was it worth it absolutely yeah
absolutely that's awesome i i love these
stories because yes there's sacrifice
yes there's uh i have to say no to the
toys and eat rice and beans or whatever
but it's for a short term for a short
amount of time in y'all's case 11 months
and now that's in the rearview mirror
you're debt-free you don't have a
payment in the world tell me how it
feels to have all that weight off your
shoulders
amazing yeah i still can't believe it's
real you know it's
it's just awesome yeah if if
i didn't use
some of the savings that i had because
there was one point i was actually at
work listening to dave
talking to a caller who called in
and she was telling dave about her
husband uh
not wanting to use the capital which is
his savings
he pretty much told her that
you using that savings is pretty much
you admitting that you took that loan
out to pay it off and at that point
i called her when she was at work i said
as soon as i get home we're paying it
off look at you you're done well done
you're done well done it's interesting
how i've noticed this in some of the
calls we get on the ramsey show
sometimes we do things that don't make
sense financially because it's
justifying something in us emotionally
it's like oh well this is not my debt or
oh i need to hold on to this because i'm
going to somehow justify this in a
backwards way it's like you know the the
shortest path between here and wealth is
just these these very simple baby steps
and when you guys put your money
together and to begin to communicate you
start to make more progress faster who
are your biggest cheerleaders
definitely our families i mean we have
the best families they're so supportive
friends my cousin um eb
yeah
he's the one that told me about dave
ramsey and that's
never look back after i still listen to
him while i'm at work that's awesome
yeah that's really cool it's amazing
what the power of having that community
around you to champion you support you
and and not make you feel so crazy for
these 11 months but man y'all busted it
78 000
in 11 months that is uh that is that is
quick how old are you guys
31 33. wow and completely debt-free
congratulations you guys what are you
going to do now now that you're
debt-free
enjoy tennessee while we're still there
our next uh goal is we're trying to you
know save to buy land and build our our
house
wow
well done y'all y'all are amazing y'all
are amazing all right we've got a copy
of the legacy journey for you guys
that's definitely the next step in your
journey we'll give you a copy of the
total money makeover as well you can
give that to a gift i mean to a friend
as a gift hopefully get them started on
their journey and uh and just love
seeing you guys win way to go all right
here we go it is time it is giovanni and
mariah from wilmington north carolina
paid off 78 000 in 11 months making 119
000
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
oh that was fast george 11 months i know
but yeah you want to do it faster and
faster and it becomes addicting and that
is the type of game i do like yes
right yes very inspiring yes i love it
the hey the the greater the sacrifice
the greater the reward the greater the
gazelle intensity the faster you get
there so yeah it's hard of course it's
hard for 11 months and now
you're debt-free in your early 30s
making 120 000 a year you're never gonna
look back and they always say it was
worth it always can always go back into
debt always
always worth it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
i'm christy wright joining me today is
george campbell and we are taking your
calls about all things money
life
side business small business uh by the
way we have our business boutique
conference coming up in october 14th
through the 16th and there are still
tickets available if you want to join us
in nashville it's a great city to
vacation to visit make it a girls trip
uh you're gonna get everything you need
to start and grow your business or you
can always join us on live stream y'all
we've done this every single year since
2015 and it is incredible lineup of
speakers it's always a really good time
and for many people it becomes the
catalyst that really um set your
business off uh we give you the tools
that you need but also the inspiration
you need you can go to
ramseysolutions.com or
businessboutique.com
to get your tickets but if you have a
question about business side business
small business leadership
george and i are here we're here to
answer your questions and help you out
all right we're gonna go to the phones
we've got renee in knoxville tennessee
hey renee how are you
i'm good how are you good what's going
on
all right well um
i am
me and my me and my boyfriend have uh
recently become engaged congratulations
and
thank you
and
we both agreed on the amount that we
would spend on the honeymoon and the
wedding
but as we are like
you know spending the money on the
different things that we need we're like
wow this is a lot of money um so we were
just wondering like we're trying to be
responsible with it while also at the
same time because code's taken so much
away we're still trying to have like a
good good wedding so
are we being responsible with our money
or or not like are we overspending on
our
on our wedding and our honeymoon when
you say you said we realized wow that's
a lot of money you mean the amount of
money you budgeted or you mean you
started actually pricing things out and
the the the quotes you're getting are
more than you expected which one are you
referring to
i would say it's just like as we were
spending the money we were like wow
that's a lot of money and because any
one of us have a fully funded emergency
fund
we were like okay yeah this is a lot of
money should we just be putting it into
our emergency fund or
you know we we are cash flowing
everything everything so
yeah it was just like as we're spending
it we're like
this is a lot of money what's the budget
what's the number y'all came up with
ten thousand for the wedding and the
honeymoon okay cool and you do you guys
have any debt
no no we're both debt-free okay what's
your you said y'all haven't got a fully
funded emergency fund yet separately or
together or whatever what's that amount
between both of y'all
between the two of us well he had six
thousand i have two thousand so together
we have eight okay cool
and uh what's your income
he makes about 2 000 a month i bring
home about seven
okay
well
here's the thing renee um
ten thousand dollars is a lot of money
for
you know a week essentially for your
wedding and um a honeymoon when you're
going oh my gosh this is a short amount
of time when you look at it through that
lens and then when you go for a wedding
budget it's actually a really
conservative budget
in the wedding industry now we're not
going to use either one of those
lenses to be the only lens we look at it
through and what's interesting about
what's interesting about money is um yes
it's it's a physical thing but it's also
emotional and so
even if if george and i said yeah i
think the amount of money you're
spending is fine you're cash flowing it
you do have some emergency fund going
you can continue to build that up you're
kind of you know setting aside this this
money for the wedding and it's not
unreasonable you're not being a diva
renee like for a wedding and a honeymoon
that's very conservative in my opinion
but
the butt here is that if you're not
comfortable with it
if you've got a check in your spirit
well it's your money and it's your
wedding and you can change the budget
you can reign it back and say hey we
feel better about eight
or we feel better about seven or
whatever
we're never gonna tell you not to
not to save money because that's always
a good idea to set you up for financial
success but i will say that in the grand
scheme of things you guys are debt free
you're smart you've got a good income
and your budget is not unreasonable at
all i think you're fine but it doesn't
matter what i think because if you feel
checked in your spirit about it then
then you're welcome to change that
george what would you say i mean this is
this is one of those it's very funny i
just did research on this because
someone asked on reddit and i haven't
you know
read it don't get me started with reddit
well here's the thing christy i thought
this is a good question they were asking
you know what is the right budget for a
wedding and there's no ramsey parameter
i can't google and say well dave says no
more than 10 000. that doesn't exist
what he says is pay cash right don't let
it be a huge you know portion of your
world and it sounds like you guys are
doing this on your own there's no family
helping out here
and so again like christy said do what
makes you comfortable but also realize
you're not a bad person weddings are
just expensive the whole industry is
basically a scam because they can charge
whatever they want people go well a
venue is what a venue costs so if you
can find ways to trim that's fine but i
want you to have a great time i don't
want you sitting there worried the whole
day that you're you're like counting the
minutes and comparing it to how much
dollars that cost going well it's a
thousand dollars an hour to throw this
party for everyone so i want you to do
it on your terms and if you're doing it
for anyone else other than yourselves
that's when i would go let's rethink
this yeah and the other thing i love how
you said that renee i mean uh george
because renee we want you to enjoy it
like this is your wedding day you don't
want to be thinking about the the dollar
per hour cost and i just want to say it
again
10 000
in the wedding industry and for i want
to reiterate wedding in honeymoon
he's really conservative that's really
conservative you guys have done well
you're not you're not being crazy here
and you're cash flowing it and so um
here's what i would say and this is in
light of george's advice i love how he
said this
you guys maybe revisit that budget and
if you're like yeah 10 is good we've
done our research we can you know 10 is
what we want to spend we're comfortable
with it then don't look back
decide on 10 commit to 10 and don't
think about it make it work within 10
but then be like we feel good about this
we're going to we're going to be excited
about this day and what we've committed
to because um you know george i'll tell
you when it comes to
like house projects like uh improving
our house we're actually doing something
right now we're paying someone to
restain our deck it's kind of worn down
i can matt and i can come up with a
number we feel good about but when it
comes time to spend it i'm still not
excited to spend the money now i'm
excited to spend money on clothes shoes
earrings fun stuff but house stuff i'm
not and and a wedding is obviously more
exciting than house stuff but sometimes
when you get into those higher dollar
amounts
it still can be emotionally hard to let
go of that amount of money even if you
know you want the thing like a stained
deck or even better
an awesome wedding and so there is
something to it of just committing be
like we're commit we're committing to
this amount of money we feel good about
it and we're not gonna look back we've
got the money we're not gonna feel
guilty
money should be enjoyed you guys and so
yeah renee i love your your question i
love how conservative you and your
husband are being uh future husband or
being and um and i hope you have a great
wedding i think you're being really
smart about it well done all right we're
gonna go to san francisco california
with marco hey marco how's it going
hi christy and george hey i'm doing good
so i had a question so i'm a high school
senior and i saved up 20 000 from a
part-time job and i would like to invest
it for a year before i go to college
and how should i
invest it to get the most money back for
a year
great question marco first of all that's
amazing yeah well done saved up 20 grand
thank you uh you're crushing it uh
there's a few ways to go about this
you're looking at a really short term uh
time here so i'm not gonna go tell you
to put it in mutual funds or you know
get some cryptocurrency
uh
i want you to be conservative here
because i don't want you to lose money
i'd rather you gain very little than
lose half of it because you know your
buddy told you to invest it over here so
if i'm in your shoes i would put it in a
good money market account you can do a
high yield savings account online i have
mine in one that pays about a half a
percent uh maybe point seven percent and
i know it's not impressive but the point
here is not to get rich quick the point
here is for you to not lose money and
just park it somewhere safe yeah the the
key here marco is access you want access
to this money so investing is a
long-term gain game and you're playing a
short-term game right now the other
thing that i want to highlight for you
marco is you are at a very
very transitional time in your life so
high school senior i think it's awesome
that you're thinking about this that is
amazing you're going to do so well in
life and you're going to be so smart
financially and you're going to be ahead
of most of your peers because you're
asking these questions
but you also don't know what changes
your life what you're going to go
through in your life in the next four to
six to eight years
in that time frame in the next decade
you're going to potentially go to
college potentially go to further
education if you want to maybe get
married maybe buy a house maybe have
kids a lot's gonna happen
all of that costs a lot of money marco
and so we definitely want you to invest
at some point in your life but right now
your first priority is going to college
debt free and the best way to do that is
to have that money in savings so you
have access to it um and that's true for
any of your savings in the next four
years you're going to put in a savings
account so that you have access to it
great question thanks for calling yeah
i want to thank my co-host george camel
and producer james producer james child
no ben hill and kelly daniel james is
out today i'm just reading the
scriptures friday ben hill kelly daniels
and you america for listening this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsay
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm christy wright i'm joined
today by my good friend george camel and
we are taking your calls
or answering your calls about money as
always but also life and business maybe
you just need help making a decision you
want someone to give you a little advice
always time management i'm on this kick
right now with my new book take back
your time the guilt-free guide to life
balance which is in pre-sale and you can
get your copy at ramseysolutions.com
amazon anywhere books are sold but we're
here for you so give us a call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and we're gonna go to miami florida with
lewis hey lewis how are you
i'm doing good about you good how can
george and i help
um so i heard about dave ramsey about a
year ago and even though i wasn't fully
on board with the baby steps and there
was my wife i saw was i was able to
change my uh my mentality and i was
about 40 000 in that and a year later uh
we're only 15 000. awesome um
but right now we're still struggling we
kind of like get back into into uh depth
a little bit and come right back out uh
but my question right now is i'm trying
to get my wife fully on board with the
baby steps
um but it's been difficult um right now
we have the fifteen thousand which is
enough in car debt
and we have 2 500 in savings and i don't
really know where to go from here okay
what's your income
your household in 145
45 for the household
great okay well talk to me a little bit
about the conversations with you and
your wife what what how how do they go
how do you talk about it what does she
say give us some context here to to this
dynamic
so one of the things that i tell her is
that um you know right now we don't have
a mortgage we
were blessed by uh
god we uh our parents more my parents
gave us a house so we don't really have
to worry about that's like our you know
we could be
debt-free you know in just a couple of
months maybe a year or something like
that and then we can uh start thinking
about our kids and their
college fund and things like that um but
she believes that if we put the money
that we have towards the car loan um we
won't have any security in case
something happens um and that's the
problem she doesn't believe that um
putting the money towards the car is is
it's a good idea right now
what do you mean security like like she
wants to put that money in savings she
wants that extra margin in your budget
exactly exactly in case not not for the
budget but just so we have the savings
yeah she doesn't believe it's worth
getting out of a car that pretty much
yeah well here's the thing lewis this
this is one of the most common calls
that we get on the ramsey show how do i
get my spouse on board
and it's one of those things that's
delicate in the sense that you can't
bulldoze your spouse and you shouldn't
it's just not good relationship best
practices to bulldoze anybody or tell
them what to do or boss them around
but you can and should have
conversations that lead to you guys
coming together now
one of the things that i think can be
helpful in leading those conversations
is you leaning on what you've learned
from the ramsay show from total money
makeover from financial peace anywhere
that you're getting our teaching on the
baby steps because
this
path of the baby steps is the shortest
distance between you and wealth there
are no exceptions
it's the shortest distance that is
security so what would be helpful i
think louis is as you guys are talking
about this
is helping her in a loving respectful
patient way
reframe what security is because you're
actually not secure when you're in debt
you owe money
to the car company to the car loan and
so
and so if if she thinks of security as
money in the bank well that
temporarily and only if you look at that
piece but that money's not even really
you also because you have this debt
weighing you down so
for a short term yes just like we were
talking about earlier there is a
sacrifice of
you're gonna you know live on as as as
low amount as you can
and take all your savings except for a
thousand dollars and put it towards that
car and you can knock that out
pretty quickly especially when you don't
have a mortgage and you don't have that
expense
but it's going to take you guys
understanding what security means and
it's not having a car loan at the same
time for you guys to have this vision of
the future the vision being debt-free
for her to get excited about what's
possible
when you're debt-free when you have no
payments that's real security that's
where you build a real savings that
makes you have that freedom of knowing
if something happens we're going to be
okay george i know you hear this a lot
because this is one of those common
things that you you typically have one
spouse that's excited and on board as we
say another spouse that's more reluctant
i tend to think i don't have any
research to back this up but i tend to
think that there's a direct correlation
between the spouse that won't get on
board and the spender like i'd be
willing to bet that never is the saver
the one that won't get on board
typically the spinner's like no no no no
uh but but what do you teach people when
you get this question because this is so
common it is a very uh regular call we
get here on the show yeah well you know
for starters you never see debt-free
screams where the spouse is there and
they go yeah i never got on board but we
made it here somehow right like so at
some point you have to get on board and
here's the thing
a lot of people go around yelling at
their spouse and they say well dave says
no there's no way here's what it needs
to change to we said and you know where
that comes from a why you need to sit
together i need to talk about your why i
want you to talk about your dreams your
goals why the heck are you getting out
of debt
and so once you do that it it doesn't
become a conversation if dave said we
can't eat out it becomes a conversation
of we said this is a priority we said
that our future goals are more important
than the things we have right now
so the why is where i always start from
there i like to move to some math
because math uh makes a lot of people
angry when you start to go hey how much
is that payment every month numbers what
would that be
yeah how much interest are we paying
goodness gracious you heard mariah in
our debt-free scream talk about how that
got her fired up seeing how much
interest she was paying and the loans
growing so start to do some math with
them and if the math doesn't work what i
love to do is say hey go
sign up for ramsay plus go through
financial peace university
and you'll hear it over and over again
people say what finally did it we went
through financial peace university and
we submitted to someone else's plan that
way it's not lewis against his spouse
it's saying hey now we're both fired up
we have common language that we can use
to talk about money to dream about our
future
and that to me is one of the biggest
things so louis what i want to do for
you is give you a one-year membership to
ramsey plus you're going to have access
to financial peace university our nine
video lesson course that's changed so
many families you'll have access to
every dollar plus for budgeting and i
think those two things going through
that with your wife she's going to get
fired up and she'll have security very
soon yeah and just at that that's a
great point so since we're giving you
that as a gift lewis all the
conversation now is just will you watch
this with me that's it you don't have to
convince her you don't have to be the
bad guy you don't have to be the dream
killer you don't have to be the security
stealer
you just say hey we watch this with me
this guy knows a lot about getting out
of debt he knows a lot about building
wealth this company has helped millions
and millions and millions of people
get out of debt and build wealth
let's just learn from them and then you
you approach it from that standpoint and
then if she's willing which i hope she
is and she certainly should be that's
such a simple ask you're making
if she's willing to watch those videos
watch how the videos transform her and
you don't have to here's what happens
and she asks questions you go we're face
to face head to head and all of a sudden
you start to do these things and you
start to look in the same direction
towards the future
hand in hand and then you're fired up
yeah that's good all right louis that's
what you're gonna do you're gonna ask
her to watch the videos in financial
peace university with you which you get
it's our course
which you get as a part of ramsey plus
and watch how that sets you on the right
path and brings you guys together
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
believe it or not y'all august is almost
over here at ramsey we think of august
as a second new year
and we've noticed that once everyone is
done with the distractions of summer
vacation
playing around going to the pool
they're ready to kick things into high
gear maybe you're like that too right
now
you still have goals that you want to
reach like saving up for christmas which
is a lot closer now than it was in
january
we know when it comes
to help you and to get you back on track
we are running deals starting at only
ten dollars and even less in some cases
and y'all we are running a specific date
uh deal today that you don't want to
miss today's one day deal is awesome and
i love it because it is around my book
and my devotional
so if you
order my book today my new book take
back your time the guilt-free guide to
life balance
you also get my devotional an ebook
version of my devotional
living true 40 days to get back to you
for free
so you can get my new book take back
your time the guilt free guide to life
balance and you get my devotional living
true 40 days to get back to you in an
ebook version completely for free you
can check it all out online
at our store at ramseysolutions.com
we're also having a lot of fun
celebrating the pre-order launch of king
coleman's new book from paycheck to
purpose
with a 3 000 cash giveaway that's ending
soon and the giveaway ends
august 31st you got a few days left to
get into this giveaway got nothing loose
3000 bucks you could gain
you can enter daily for extra chances to
win at the ramsey cash giveaway no
purchase necessary must be 18 or older
to win text cash to three three seven
eight nine to enter that's cash to three
three seven eight nine to enter y'all we
have a lot of exciting stuff going on
we've got two books that are in pre-sale
mine and ken coleman's we're running
sales at ramsey solutions.com we've got
a cash giveaway at ramseysolutions.com
there's a lot going on
and you guys ought to take advantage of
it just listening to it it's not going
to change anything
it's when you actually take action
you know george i've been on this uh
this kick lately where i don't know
where people came up with the idea of
it's the thought that counts
no it's not
no it's not who told you that that is a
bold face lie
listen you're not bragging to your
friends about what your husband thought
about getting you for your anniversary
oh you're not posting on facebook about
the grades your child thought about
getting it's a personal attack christy
listen it's not the thought that counts
people it's what you do that counts and
if you want different results you're
going to need do need to do something
different go to rmc solutions.com take
advantage of these sales y'all get them
for yourself get them as a gift
get some new information that will help
you take different actions which lead to
different results that's good was that
in one of your books that's really good
i'm gonna steal that if not i'll always
tweet it i'll tag you okay
so i think you mentioned so many things
you forgot the goal planner i know and
the goal planner's on sale as well that
always sells out don't call me crying in
january it's gonna be gone by then but
yes that's at ramsey solutions.com as
well you can set your goals plan your
calendar manage your time we just want
to help you do all the things manage
your money your time your career
all of it we're here for you and you can
call me crying yes
that's fine i'll be here post post on
reddit tell us how you feel george will
be the only one that reads that the only
one hanging out there i can guarantee
you that all right let's go to renee in
alexandria virginia hey renee how are
you
hi christy thanks for taking my call um
my husband and i are 44 and 41 and we're
kind of stuck in 3b four and five
all at the same time with life happening
and not really sure where to give
um our focus
okay well tell me about what's going on
what are your goals and what's kind of
the situation you're in
so we have about eight hundred thousand
dollars in retirement
um we
make two hundred and thirty thousand
dollars a year we have about seventy
dollars in savings
we
and we don't own a house we've lived
here for four years and we are not
interested in buying in the area that
we're in the houses here are extremely
expensive
but we still want to be saving for a
house because i feel the pressure of
being 44 and that home having a house
and knowing that i need to be on a
15-year fix at some point
um so there's that and then i only put
10 percent into tsp
um sorry my husband i work for the
federal government so um i put in 10 he
puts in seven and honestly i don't feel
like i have more money to put in at this
point so i'm kind of doing step four and
then step five we're cash flowing my
husband's master's degree which he will
finish up this december and we just had
a son enter junior college and he wants
to cash flow his college as well i'm not
as much on board that's a whole weather
story so we're kind of in three steps at
the same time and i'm not really sure
where to put my focus and i cut and i
feel broke all the time i feel like i'm
back in my baby step one days when i was
here baby step two paying off debt um
because i'm pulling myself in so many
different directions i'm not really sure
what to do yeah
um well first of all you're not broke
let's let's just start there renee you
have eight hundred thousand dollars in
retirement you're almost a millionaire
okay your household income is over two
hundred thousand dollar years which is
well above the national average you're
not even close to broke not even like a
little tiny bit do y'all have any debt
no debt okay
okay so so here's one of the things
that's difficult can be difficult about
the later baby steps that's a little
different than one two and three
they do happen simultaneously and in
your case saving for a house is kind of
lumped into this this latter part of the
baby steps so they do happen
simultaneously
the
the good part of this is um unlike when
your gazelle intense getting out of debt
you do take your foot off the gas a
little bit because this is a marathon
not a sprint it's ongoing this is going
to take a much longer period of time to
do these things to pay off your home uh
you know fund college or investing for
the long haul these are these are things
that are ongoing so that's the good part
the downside is
because you're you're you really have
multiple goals going on at one time
you can feel like you're not making
progress in any of them just because it
is maybe a slower progress divided
right and so one of the things that i
think would be helpful for you aside
from the thing that you mentioned about
um you know the the
the funding your your child's college
which is a different question like you
said but i think one of the things that
would be helpful is if you set
micro goals if you set smaller goals how
much do we want to have in our house
fund by christmas how much do we want to
have by march of next year by august of
next year and start to set these smaller
goals that are almost by quarter there's
several months you start to get some
some mile markers here
where you can see your progress in the
house savings department
and then with the child's college if you
guys get on the same page whatever you
decide to do there you can do the same
thing in terms of how much investing is
not as much of an issue number one
because you have eight hundred thousand
dollars number two because you don't
have a home so we're almost kind of
backtracking a little bit to to
uh get some savings to be able to buy a
house in in your case but what's
interesting
renee is research show this
psychological psychology research shows
this
that nothing is more motivating
than seeing progress made
not money not rewards not applause not
affirmation it's seeing oh i saw i lost
five pounds that makes me want to go
work out more oh i saw i paid off a
credit card and cut it up that makes me
want to pay off the next one so when you
begin to see your progress in saving for
a home it's going to actually motivate
you to make more progress i think you're
not seeing your progress because you're
not tracking it and you're not setting
these smaller goals and so that's one of
the things that will help you
continue to make progress in each of
these areas
because they do happen simultaneously uh
but actually feel like you're making
progress there george you have been on
this one because this the baby steps
four five and six especially when you're
saving for a house that can be a little
different it can get tricky so uh like
christy said renee you're doing an
amazing job and i feel like you've got a
lot of stress and i feel it in your
voice there's just a lot going on but i
want you to take a deep breath and go
we have done really well yeah and we've
worked really hard i mean the fact i
don't even know how you guys have 800
000 in retirement this is i mean it's
incredible at 40. so here's my thing if
you want to feel progress there's
nothing wrong with pausing that
investing right now because you're doing
so great and then just stacking up that
down payment focus on one thing right
now
if you know depending on the college
situation i want them to cash flow i'm
with i'm with your kid on that one i
want them to cash flow because i heard
too many heartbreaking stories uh
hosting the borrowed future podcast uh
to hear about that so pause it get that
house down payment saved up to focus on
a goal go back to investing and make it
15
and then start funding the college and
get that house you're gonna do great you
guys have already done great it's gonna
feel a little weird to you renee because
you've been investing so well for so
long to pause that but that's the reason
that baby step comes before three comes
before four is because we're assuming
that you're going to buy a house before
you start investing so you have that
that money for the down payment you've
been doing it so it may seem
counterintuitive to pause it but it's
actually going to give you more money to
fund the house when you find the house
you want and you're ready and then you
can ramp it back up by the way you
almost have a million dollars there
you're doing great you're doing great
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright george kim and i are
taking your calls today about money life
and business give us call triple eight
eight two five
two
we love talking to you and we love
hearing your questions we can process it
with you give you some advice
help you think through tough decisions
or maybe you just need another
perspective we're here for you triple
eight eight two five 825-5225
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online online retailer of
custom window coverings you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promo codes they run every month you'll
save even more
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal
today's question comes from ben in
pennsylvania ben asks i have enough
money to buy an engagement ring but
including that amount i would have
enough money to pay off my auto loan the
only other debt i have is a student loan
buying the ring keeps the car debt
around for a few more months but paying
off the truck essentially puts off a
wedding for a few months should i buy
the ring or pay off the car loan
yeah it's a good question well you know
the interesting thing is uh we're
talking about a pretty short time frame
here it's a few months
my gut i mean you can make an argument
either way honestly like if you want to
if you want to get your wedding going
whatever but if i were you since we're
talking about a few months and you're
not just dying to get married this
minute i'd pay off the truck it's one
less debt you're going into your
marriage and engagement with and
you've got that money yeah it frees up a
payment and honestly with how things are
going right now in the world i think
putting off the wedding for a few months
may be a safe bet
so maybe that'll buy you some time it'll
help you cash flow this wedding easier
you're going to free up a payment with
that truck which means you're going to
save up for that engagement ring really
fast if that that money is going to go
towards that and as long as you know
your uh future fiance is on board with
this plan you know i don't know what you
the conversations have been like around
this but
make sure it's not a huge surprise where
they go oh my gosh i already set the
date and now this is throwing everything
off so um i like the idea of paying off
the truck if it's not going to slow down
this wedding by a huge amount of time
because of that freedom payment you're
actually going to gain income by paying
off the truck whereas buying the ring
won't do anything for you there yeah no
i think that's i think that's the right
thing to do the other thing is um to
your point george we don't know all the
context around it but if there have been
any type of communications or
expectations that something's happening
in a certain timeframe definitely talk
to your fiance about it you don't want
her you know getting her nails done
every week thinking the ring's coming
any minute and you've you know you've
pushed it back a few months and it's so
stressful yeah it is so stressful it's
funny though because when you're in that
season of life
every day feels like an eternity of like
everything feels like such a big deal
and gosh i look back on when matt and i
got married i'm like oh we were babies
like that just feels like forever ago
it's all just in the moment it feels so
urgent and yeah you want to get married
you guys are excited of course but a few
months that's one less debt you're going
into your engagement with and um and to
your point george you've got that you've
got that payment that you're putting
towards the truck now to save even
faster for the ranks way to go ben i'm
excited for you guys congratulations all
right let's go to oklahoma city oklahoma
with tom hey tom how are you
i'm good how are y'all good what's going
on
so i just started listening to y'all and
i bought the money makeover book about a
month ago and my wife and i are on baby
step number two
she's more of the free spirit and i'm
really
tight on my budget and you know strict
with money and everything
to where sometimes it gets or starts
arguments between us
but uh we recently got rid of a bring
the vehicle because we had two of them
and i have to put down a big circular
change to be able to pay it off and sell
it
so now we're down to one vehicle and
we're having a little issue now to where
we think we need a second one
and because of my work schedule i find
myself needing a vehicle during the week
while she's gone
and so the question is
should i
trade in the vehicle and try to get two
loans for
i guess two vehicles
for i guess around the same price or
same loan amount every month for this
one
or just keep this vehicle and
put money down that i have in savings on
a used vehicle so we have a second one
give us some more information how much
savings do you have how much money do
you make and how much debt do you have
so right now
i make about 89 a year and then that's
with my work and disability
and then the debt we have is around 252
and 615.
what kind of debt is that
a home in the truck okay without the
house take the house out of it what kind
of debt do you have
uh the truck is 31 530 and that's the
only thing we have
how much is it worth
i got an appraised dealership for right
under 31 about 30
500.
that's what they would give you for a
trade in
yes
well you could sell for private party
more than that
and used cars are going for crazy prices
right now
uh how much do you have in savings yeah
i'm getting four to put down about nine
but right now we have about eleven
thousand in savings
eleven thousands of savings okay
um
george and i will tag team on this one
but we're gonna tell you the same thing
and it's not to take out a loan it's to
get you two
used cars that get you around in cash
and you've got the cash to do it um
this
you could sell that truck private party
and pay off that debt and um use your
savings you could you could use
everything but a thousand bucks well
just let's just think about this for a
second time okay just go with me here i
know it's not what you asked and i know
it's not what you want but just go with
me anyway because you called and you're
gonna get the truth from us if you were
to sell that truck private party pay off
your debt
you leave a thousand dollars in your
emergency fund and buy two five thousand
dollar cars which you can do that are
good dependable used cars
you are not going to be in those cars
very long
before you can save up and pay cash to
upgrade that car you make a good income
and you will be debt-free in that one
decision
if you do this you will be debt free
instantly
and then you can upgrade your car soon
and and not have to be having this
payment dragging around george am i
missing something here yeah tom this is
what i'm feeling out of this situation
like christy said absolutely not don't
get a loan
if you go to karvana.com
vroom.com carmax.com a local dealership
just go through all of those and see
what you can get for this truck and with
that money i want you to get two used
cars that are decent and you could pay
10 or 15 for each of those and with your
11k in savings and making some money out
of this deal you could be at baby step
four you might have a fully funded
emergency fund with no payments in the
world other than that mortgage to tackle
and you'll be investing 15 at that point
in baby step four and if you've got kids
or you do in the future you can save up
for college and then we're going to look
at paying off the house early so i love
this because it's an easy decision for
me it might be a difficult one
for tom because
i know some guys out there like their
cars and it's emotional and it's
sentimental and you go i don't want a
car that i don't like to drive and like
christy said this is temporary down the
line you can save up and pay cash for a
30 000 car if you really want it later
on but right now you've got to clean up
this mess what i love is that you could
do it today that's right we have some
people call tom and they have you know
they are going they're at the beginning
of a three-year journey of paying off
their debt you could have this fixed
this week i mean you're in an awesome
position it is going to require some
sacrifice a different mentality to say
okay short term i'm going to give up
this awesome 30 000 car
for a 5 000 car and so my wife can have
a car
the great news is you have this savings
so you have it's not even setting you
back for very long because you're gonna
you're gonna drive this car
for
i don't know six months or a year maybe
and you're gonna be able to save up pay
cash for a nicer newer car whenever
you're you're ready to but the truth is
the car that you have
because it's on debt you can't afford it
if you could have afforded you would pay
cash so all you're gonna do is just sell
that
and buy something in cash for the short
term and then from here on out
you're buying cars in cash and um and
and you're going to be in such a better
position whenever you do that then you
don't have those payments and you're
moving into baby steps four five and six
like george said where you're investing
you're building wealth you're paying off
the house and you're not paying all the
interest that you're paying right now in
this car and so um that's what we were
do you can do what you want to that's
what we always say you can do what you
want to that's what we would do if we
were you and that's going to be the
quickest path to you getting out of debt
stop losing money on all this interest
and actually building wealth
take your cash buy two cheaper cars sell
that car that you have get rid of that
debt you're gonna be debt free this week
if you do it tom debt free no payments
you can do this i think you should this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm christy wright george campbell and i
are hosting the ramsey show today for
you and
we love hanging out with you guys we
love taking your calls hearing your
stories and of course answering your
questions give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five
george campbell's new podcast the fine
print is out and available wherever you
listen to podcasts and y'all this is um
such a cool
effort and project that our entire
company has rallied behind because
george is really exposing a lot of the
lies and myths that are holding you back
and keeping you broke i love the first
two episodes i love the titles because
they are just in your face which you all
know i love i just like that i just love
being direct enneagram eight i'm like
let's just call it number one how turbo
tax is screwing you
okay well that's pretty clear i love a
good clear title
and uh number two the true cost of
credit card rewards both of those are
out now listen to them wherever you
listen to podcasts support george and
also just get some great information
that you need that's going to help you
break free from stuff that's holding you
back with your money which is what we're
here to help you do
also want to remind you
my new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance is
available for pre-sale and if you order
your copy before pre-sale ends and it
ends in just
about a week or two
um you're gonna get all this free stuff
you're gonna get the e-book the
audiobook a ticket to my live event in
september
which by the way you can join us here in
nashville in person or you can join on
live stream you're going to get access
to a private facebook group with me
where i go live and coach you between
now and then we want to give you all of
the bonus items all the free stuff to
say thank you for pre-ordering because
it helps us with our marketing we're not
trying to hide anything we just tell you
it helps us that's why we do pre-sale
can coleman's new book is also in
pre-sale and that's why we do it that
way is because it helps us and then we
help you
when we give you all that good free
stuff you can get all of that
at
ramseysolutions.com and by the way uh
we're running a sale today if you order
a copy of take back your time in
addition to all that stuff i just said
you also get a free copy of my
devotional an ebook of living true 40
days to get back to you you get all this
stuff it's a lot of stuff you could give
some of it away for christmas gifts just
get your copy then to give out all that
other stuff for christmas guess i'm
helping you christmas shop early look at
that and save on your budget because you
get it free oh yeah um all right we're
gonna go to jacob in nashville my
hometown of nashville tennessee where we
are hey jacob how are you
good how are you all good what's going
on
well first thank you so much for taking
my call um so
in about eight days i'm getting married
congratulations
thank you so much we're very excited um
she has been awesome she's got a great
job she's paid off all of her debt she
actually just paid off her car
she's got
at least three months of expenses saved
up
i tend to be on the other end of the
spectrum i just graduated from pa school
um got a job
but with that came about 180 000 worth
of student debt
um
and so
combined we'll be making a pretty great
income of we'll be bringing home about
200 000 a year
and
so we'd be able to pay on
my debt pretty quickly and we both want
to do that but i also wanted to call and
say you know because i've been looking
at the baby steps and
given that we will be making so much
money and my minimum payment is only
2100 a month which
we're going more only
that's more than my mortgages just a
small 2100 go on jacob i'm with you
well yeah i didn't mean to say like that
but yeah um
we
were thinking you know taking the extra
income that we'll have on top of already
paying over on my student debt
and jumping to one of the later baby
steps then saving 15
or going ahead and making sure that we
do have our three months expenses
you know saved and doing
that's the very short answer to your
opinion was yes so um the short answer
is no
that's the very short answer to that the
reason is jacob for um for over 30 years
and millions and millions of people the
baby steps are in that order for a
reason and it's because it's the
shortest path between you
and wealth
when you have debt any type of debt any
interest rate any time frame for your
payments it doesn't matter i don't care
what the fine print is on your debt it's
always
a risk
it's always stealing your income and
stealing your future so our number one
goal is to get it out of here our number
one goal is to get rid of any type of
debt at any amount at any interest rate
so
should you fast forward and skip baby
steps no
never not ever not ever in any situation
what we want to do is you're going to be
making hundred thousand dollars a year
you've got a hundred and what in 180
something a thousand eighty yeah okay
i want you to live on nothing
for that first year or two
and you can get this knocked out really
quickly and then you can save up your
emergency fund and then you can invest
and you can do so with unbelievable
momentum and progress and margin and
control and no risk and no worries and
no payments
and that's the way that we want you to
do it and i don't want you to
um i don't want you to feel bad
about getting married and bringing all
this debt in because with that debt um
you're gonna work as a team and get it
paid off you're gonna have a great
income both of you are gonna have great
incomes and in eight days
you are becoming one which means your
bank accounts are becoming one your
goals are becoming one
and so um
i know sometimes it can be hard for the
person coming into marriage
that has the debt to feel like oh my
gosh i just need to pay this off on my
own there's this temptation like i don't
want to drag you down
you're going to drag you both down if
you don't work as a team you got to
combine y'all's income y'all's goals
y'all's effort y'all's focus to get this
knocked out and when you do y'all will
both make progress faster you will make
so much more progress than if you try to
do this separately individually any kind
of sneaky skip and baby steps leapfrog
we don't we don't do that this is
because this order works and we want to
get that out of here as soon as possible
yeah absolutely you know in 30 years of
doing the show i don't think i've ever
heard dave say you get to leapfrog the
baby steps yeah and jacob i'm sure
you're a unique you're uniquely created
by god you're special but you're not
special when it comes to the babysitter
that's special jacob christie gave me
the why and the heart behind it let me
give you the how and the what and the
tactical here yep you don't make two
hundred thousand starting today you make
fifty thousand dollars and after taxes
my guess is you guys bring you and you
bring home 150 right so you're gonna put
a hundred thousand dollars towards this
debt and this thing's going to be gone
in under two years and if you have any
savings we're throwing that on there
except for a thousand dollars for that
starter emergency fund and here's what's
gonna happen you're gonna start to
believe that you can get rid of 180
thousand dollars in under two years
and you know how i know it can happen
because you have an amazing income and
you have an amazing wife who's gonna be
on board who's gonna get fired up with
this about you uh with you and then
guess what in less than two years you
guys have a giant pile of money to throw
at the emergency fund and you'll be
investing in no time
jacob stay on the line i want um kelly
to give you and your
fiance a membership to ramsay plus this
is our proven course but we also have
our our budgeting app inside there uh
financial peace universities inside rmc
plus we've got all this content and
teaching and what's going to be cool is
in the next two years which is a
marathon for you
while you're tackling this debt together
it's going to keep you inspired it's not
just going to give you the tools to do
it which you'll have that which is great
it's also going to keep you motivated
and inspired that'll give you some of
the language to talk about when you'll
have your budget meetings and to you
know even as a newlywed couple just to
get on the same page with your finances
whatever your finances are it gives you
something to talk about it gives you
some language around it it's going to
give you that motivation so stay on the
line we'll give you that as a wedding
gift and congratulations listen if you
if you do this
if you do it like george and i are
telling you if you knock it out if you
live like you're living on fifty
thousand dollars
you know if you live on hardly anything
you've got so much margin to put to that
and then you are going to have so much
money when it's gone if you let it hang
around you will not have so much money
you will make a really good income and
continue to feel broke and you're not
broke you're just choosing to let that
stick around and we don't want that to
happen and so um knock it out you can do
it and then give us a call in less than
two years when you're debt-free and you
do that debt-free scream and george and
i will be celebrating you george when um
matt and i got married i did not have
any debt i paid off my last final debt
my car payment right before uh he
proposed the week before he proposed i
didn't know he was proposing that weed
it was just great timing um but i didn't
bring any savings into our marriage and
he had savings and i remember feeling a
sense of guilt because we had to pay for
our wedding and some stuff by ourselves
and so there was a little i didn't have
the debt i was bringing but i had the
lack of savings and sometimes when
there's an inequality yeah you can feel
like the bad guy you're not the bad guy
you made bad decisions you're a
different person you're doing things
differently and matt of course was
filled with grace but man when you bring
your money together and you work as a
team changes everything everything
changes that's such a good call out
everything all right i want to thank
producer ben hill
and associate producer kelly daniel and
my co-host george campbell and you
america for hanging out with us this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money
i'm christy wright and i am joined today
by my good friend george camel
we are taking your calls triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
have a question about money we are here
for you
if you have a question about life
maybe a relationship question
a tough decision you've got to make a
career question a side business small
business question y'all know before i
was talking about time management life
balance i was talking about business
still talking about business we have our
business boutique conference coming up
in october but i love to help you so
maybe you have an idea and you're not
sure if it could be a business
or you have a business and you're
feeling burned out
or you're not sure how to monetize your
idea give us a call triple eight eight
two five five
george's new podcast called the fine
print is out wherever you listen to
podcasts he is exposing the lies the
myths that are keeping you broke and
stuck
he is helping you know what you need to
know
to be set free from that and i am just
i'm loving the titles of these podcasts
they are sassy they are direct he is
just taking on some of these industries
that are keeping you down and uh and you
need to listen to it so the fine print
is available wherever you listen to
podcasts
and uh most of you guys know but the um
the new
book from me take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance is
available on pre-sale
by the way
uh the gold planner is out as well so we
just launched that last week we're not
really talking about it that much yet uh
but it did sell out early last year it
always does it it sold out particularly
early last year george and people were
messaging me mid-december people get
angry is there any way is there any way
can you find one is there one here i
might like buy them and resell them on
ebay like a thousand dollars you i think
you could that might be the move people
like can i have the one that's in the
back of your your bookshelves at your
facebook live from home i'm like that's
up no you can't
well there's a reason christy it's not
just a normal goal planner it's not just
a calendar you throw so much content and
thoughtful effort into this goal planner
and that is that is why people love it
well it thank you and you're right you
know one of the interesting things so
i'll give you guys a little a little
family talk here a little behind the
scenes pull the curtain back on ramsey
solutions i'd like to share with you
guys uh not just uh why we do what we do
but even how we do what we do kind of
behind the scenes that you all may not
see
so when we were first having discussions
uh i guess four years ago five years ago
about a planner i knew that that there
was a whole group of people that really
use planners they we were big goal
oriented people here we teach people to
have goals i was like there's such a
connection there between the market that
needs a planner to help them with goals
and and we love goals we teach goals
we've got to do this
but to be honest many people don't use
just a paper planner they use their
phone they use their apps their
calendars their digital calendars and
that makes perfect sense i get that so
though what do i use well i read books
for personal development growth and
leadership
i do bible studies uh that will have
journal questions for reflection i use
tools and templates for things whether
it's for my you know social media for
work or for um you know even goals you
know goal trackers and that type of
thing
and so i was like and then i used a
calendar so i was like how can i combine
all this so literally we took all of
those pieces and put them in there so
every month has teaching that's the book
piece of it teaching on a different
aspect of your life
from your uh the power of your mind to
um your relationships your resources
your money and so on um all the way to
you've got the actual journal questions
to help you put that into practice
you've got tools and templates to help
you live it out and then of course you
have your monthly and weekly calendar
you even have a month in review where
we're going to review how this month
went before you set goals for the next
month so this is a great tool
to help you actually stick with your
goals next year we launch it in august
to give you plenty of time to buy it get
your copy before the year is up to get
ready for next year get it for christmas
get it for a gift um and then also it's
one of those things that because it does
sell out you want to get it early and we
want to give you time to do this so you
can get the 2022 goal planner
from me at ramseysolutions.com store get
your copy early because they do
sell out every single time all right
let's go to kendra in nashville
tennessee hey kendra how are you
i'm okay how are you good what's going
on
um
first of all thank you for taking my
call and i'm gonna try and explain this
the best way that i know how um
i
my husband just recently left me for
another woman so i lost his income
but i've decided to get on dave ramsey's
bandwagon here and contacted all my
creditors
a few years ago we had bought a lemon of
a car and
voluntarily surrendered it
the original cost of it was just over
seven thousand dollars but they're
willing to forgive it for a little over
two thousand
but they're only
accepting payments for three months
so do i go ahead and try to knock this
out now or
do i need to treat it as a vet snowball
or what should i do i don't know what to
do kendra
i'm so sorry that happened
thank you i hear your question about
money
i'm so sorry that happened
i can't
imagine
the heartbreak
the betrayal
i'm so sorry
you didn't deserve that
nobody deserves that
thank you
i want you to know that you're strong
i want you to know
that you're going to get through this
even though it doesn't feel like it it
will not hurt this bad forever
you will get through this
you will be stronger
you will
and you are worthy of love
and this is not a reflection on you
at all
this is this is the statement of him and
who he is and his character
not you
and i want to start there okay
thank you i want you to get that
in your head in your heart i want you to
write it down
i want you to be listening to podcasts i
want you to be reading scripture i want
you to get into church i want you to be
around amazing friends i want people to
love you and grab you by the shoulders
and look you in the eyes and tell you
that again and again and again as many
times as you need it
as you get through this okay
that's number one
okay
okay
second of all
yes get rid of it
pay it off as quick as you can get those
people
get that car get the paperwork get the
headache get the risk
get it out of here
get the memory of that
you get it out there and then from there
you organize your debts
smallest to largest just like we teach
but yes you get it out of there
but i just
the number one thing
that is important to kinder right now
is taking care of kendra
the number one thing
you're not going to be able to manage
your money you're not going to be able
to make good financial decisions you're
not going to do anything unless you take
care of kendra
so we're going to take care of kendra
i want you to stay on the line
and i'm gonna have kelly give you a um
membership to ramsay plus
that is our platform where we have all
of our teaching all of our tools all of
our content everything that helps you
walk out these baby steps that's going
to love you encourage you and give you
the tactical teaching you need
to do the baby steps as you walk this
out
but even as you do this
i want you to remember what i said
the first thing you need to do is take
care of you
you get around people that love you
they're going to speak truth to you and
remind you of just
how
valuable
you are how worthy of love that you are
that this is not about you
this was about him
and you're gonna get through this
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
when you're struggling with money it's
easy to tell yourself that you'll deal
with it later or you'll start fresh in
the new year but then later rolls around
and you still feel out of control
don't wait around and wish you would
have started earlier
decide
right now
that this is the last month you will
ever worry about money again
if you do
if you're ready we're here to help
that's why for this month only we're
knocking 30 off a 12-month membership to
our most impactful
life changing
money classes and products with the
ramsey plus membership you'll get access
to financial peace university our
step-by-step plan to save money pay off
debt and build wealth
plus you get the premium version of our
every dollar budgeting tool to help you
put that plan into action and take
control of your money
you deserve a life free of monthly
payments and constant money stress
start your free trial of ramsay plus
today by texting trial to
33789 that's trial to
seven eight 33789 you guys have heard us
multiple times today george and myself
giving away giving away
a year membership to ramsey plus and
there's a reason for that
it's because it is what will help you
get control of your money it's not just
a random coincidence that we're talking
about it that when people call in and
they have a question they're confused or
they're lost or they're stuck or they're
hurting we go hey you know what stay on
the line we're going to give you a gift
of ramsay plus it's because it is the
class
the budgeting tool
the app that is going to get you out of
the mess that you feel like you're in
with your money and help you
break free and build wealth that's why
we talk about it
that's why we want you to get it because
it will help you
build wealth and get out of debt
that's trial two three three seven eight
nine
text trial two three three seven seven
eight nine you can start a free trial
try it out
no risk you don't pay anything if you
change your mind but give it a try
all right we're going to go to jerry in
atlanta hey jerry how are you
i'm doing quite well thank you very much
i hope the two of you are doing well as
well yeah what's going on
my question relates out we're at babysit
four five and six and um both are in our
close to retirement age i'm 65 my wife
is 60.
and we're we've done quite well uh
staying debt-free we've got our
retirement set up we have an opportunity
to move back to where we actually came
to atlanta from
and looking at that i'm seeing that we
would make enough from the proceeds of
our home to be able to pay cash for a
home in in the state we want to move to
the challenge that comes into play there
is probably doing the right thing at the
right time moment because in order to do
that we will be putting about 850 miles
between us and our two grandsons that
live here in the atlanta area they're 35
miles away we would then be about 850
miles away from them however there is
the
opportunity for us to take what we would
have been paying for a house payment and
just shock that away
and make that be part of kind of a fund
that we could use to you know bring them
to us and have them stay for lengths of
time or us travel back here for lots of
times so it's kind of a dilemma for us
because it's it's kind of a challenge we
have family and friends back in the
other state as well but this one is kind
of a tough decision and just kind of
wondered where that balance might fit
for you that is hard jerry what are the
ages of your grandkids
six and four
okay
well i'm going to ask you a question and
it may not be a clear answer but it's
just a good exercise even if it's
something you have to think about after
we get off the phone
so when decisions are hard and they
often are
you know in my book take back your time
i actually give
eight different questions to ask
yourself when you're faced with a tough
decision and you don't have to ask all
eight of them that would be super
overwhelming but they're examples of
things that can help you
as you wrestle through decisions
one of the questions that i want to ask
you this is an example from my book but
i want to ask you in light of this
situation
which will you regret
now the reason i ask it that way is
because sometimes it brings a different
level of clarity when you fast forward
and project out into the future and
imagine your life in this scenario we've
stayed in atlanta
we're you know paying more for house
and we're with our grandkids as they
grow up or project out project out the
other scenario we've paid cash for a
house we're with some friends but our
grandkids are far away
sometimes when you project out in the
future and you look back on the decision
through the lens of which one would i
regret it brings a different level of
clarity so i want you to think about
that jerry is there one that comes to
mind or rises to the surface when you
look about look at it through that lens
um yeah and i think we've thought about
that numerous times as we've been
wrestled with the decision and of course
the tub to have the boys just because
they're just so incredibly adorable
of course they are
essentially i still have a probably five
good years in need before i will need to
can retire
and then get the freedom of being able
to travel back and forth but
i may be looking at this more of an
economic decision as opposed to a
personal decision so the regret part of
it
probably hasn't come into our thought
process yet but that's a great question
well it's something you can think about
and i'll tell you there are some calls
on this show where it is like yes you
absolutely should should do this this is
a strictly financial this is right this
is wrong
this is one of those where it's more of
a values decision we're not going to be
mad at you if you decide to stay in
atlanta and pay more because you'll be
close to your grandkids and we're not
going to be mad if you decide to move
this is your life jerry and ultimately
comes down to you and your wife's
decision
i will tell you what i hear as the
mother of three kids aged six four
and one
my mother-in-law and father-in-law are
actually stopping by the show here in a
little bit today and they live in
florence alabama which is two hours from
nashville where we live
they see them about once a month
definitely sometimes more frequently
than that um but at the at the least
once a month once every three weeks
and every time they see them
they say oh they've grown up
oh my gosh they've changed so much
oh my gosh so much has happened in three
weeks
and so i hear that so i can't
separate myself from that totally when i
advise you jerry because to me
um family is everything that's my
personal values
family's everything there's no amount of
money in the world
that would that would make me want to be
away from my mom for my in-laws for my
dad
but that's me you know everyone doesn't
have those same family ties everyone
doesn't have that same family pull
um but but you can think about it you
can think about which which one you will
regret because ultimately i want to
advise you in the direction of no
regrets
and i will encourage one other
alternative here
sometimes we tend to think of things as
these extremes like i've got this
extreme option or this extreme option i
just want to challenge you is there an
option in between is there an option in
atlanta where you could downsize in your
house or find something more on the
outskirts of town or something that's a
little bit cheaper that helps you make
progress on your financial goals if you
want to to pay a little less but you're
still close to your family so i want to
throw that out there as an option as
well george you hop in here yeah here's
my take you know my family is in boston
massachusetts my wife's family they're
moving to florida and we don't have kids
yet and we're going man when we have
kids it's going to be kind of sad to not
have the grandparents so close by so if
i'm you guys it i'm like hey they're
going to be this age for a little while
you know in 10 years they're going to be
in high school and going to college and
they'll kind of be doing their own thing
so to me i'm like can you hang out in
that area for maybe another 10 years as
they grow up and you get to be with them
way more frequently and then once you
guys are you know in maybe 70 75 you can
go retire
back to your hometown and retire there
and have a great life and you can pay
for those trips yeah you know one of the
things that um
that my mother-in-law said to me jerry
in relation to my kids um and she said
you know there's a very short
time frame when they want to go to mimi
and pops my sons today at school mimi
and pop wouldn't pick them up from
school and uh carter is in first grade
and conley's in in pre-k five and they
are so excited they can't see street
because they get to go to meeting pops
today and mimi and pop are picking them
up from school like today is basically
the greatest day in the world because
mimi and pop are picking them up from
school and my mother-in-law very wisely
pointed out to me she said there's only
a short frame of time where they feel
like that when they're 17 they're not
going me me and pause they're probably
not wanting to go
honest they don't they won't like us
either when they're 17 so we all know
that time is coming but in this season
jerry um i think that that might be
something to to consider because this is
a really special time and to your point
you've got five more years um you know
before you retire anyway it's not that
you can't move back out there they just
walked in my little ones just walked in
it's not that you can't i know i was
just talking about them it's not that
you can't uh move out there but maybe
maybe just put it off like george said
so you get to cherish these sacred
years
when they're little they're only little
ones
but you got this thanks for calling
jerry
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
homeschool parents we get it
preparing your teen for the real world
can feel scary
especially when it comes to teaching
them complicated money topics like
compound interest taxes and insurance
but you can do it and our homeschool
curriculum can help foundations and
personal finance has helped over 5
million students learn the money lessons
they need to thrive now
and in the future how incredible is that
and the best part gone are the late
nights of lesson planning this
curriculum already has activities videos
lesson plans and assessments already
done for you
video content and activities already
created
parents text homeschool to 33789 to
learn more about our life-changing
personal finance curriculum for middle
and high school students
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is my good friend george camel we are
here for you give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five if you've got a
question about money
time management
business leadership whatever you need we
are here for you it's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five and we're gonna go to
scottsdale arizona with alexis hey
alexis how are you
good how are you good what's going on
good so i just had a question i'm 20 and
i have 56 000 in the bank account which
is growing every day however i have
absolutely no idea what to do with this
money as it's in the account but it's
not making any interest well what a
great problem to have
i've got 56 000. i don't know what to do
christy and george help me okay where
did this come from
let's start there
um so i actually own a furniture company
where i buy bursted furniture and i flip
it on instagram cool
i love this election up your alley how
long have you been doing it
um i've been doing it for about three
months now
whoa whoa whoa alexis you've been doing
this three months and you've made 56 000
off of this
so the 56 000 isn't just from that
previous to owning the furniture
business i've also owned a few other
businesses um but i have stopped doing
that within the last three months okay
and so now it's just the furniture
business that i'm doing
super cool okay do you have any debt
um i only have my car debt how much is
that
um so right now i have at least and my
grandparents pay half of it so my
monthly payment is 200 a month and
that's the only bit i have
what is the car worth
i want to say 53 000
i just got it okay
yeah okay um
any other debt
no president
okay
george i'm gonna let you take the debt
part of this and uh and then we'll talk
about the emergency fund and kind of
going from there yeah so what is your
income
so my income is around
maybe like it ranges from eight to ten
thousand a month
awesome you're rocking it like 20 years
old yeah there's a lot of good things
happening here yeah
so here's what i want you to do i want
to get this debt out of your life
because you have too many good things to
let this be holding you back
i don't like leases it is one of the
most expensive ways to operate a vehicle
and with your income and your hustle you
can go pay cash for a car and then and
your savings yeah and your savings
so talking about the savings there's a
lot we can do with that if you're you
said you're new to the plan here
yeah so i've never done any plans before
well you've done really well for no plan
let's start with that alexis
so we teach the seven baby steps here at
ramsey solutions and uh we've we've
taken calls during this show where
people want to leapfrog they want to do
it their own way and that's fine but
you're not going to get the results that
you want doing that and so here's what i
want you to do
we start with a baby step one starter
emergency fund of one thousand dollars
so everything but that we're gonna go
and pay off the debt with that in baby
step two so we're gonna pay off all of
our debts from smallest to largest you
just have the car from what you told me
so you're gonna want to get the full
buyout amount from the dealership or
wherever you're leasing it from and you
could pay that in full and get rid of
this thing today so i do like that
that's great news got it um and then
with the money left over you can get a
good used car for now i mean you're
going to be in a really good spot soon
once you pay off that car and you get a
fully funded emergency fund and baby
step three
that's going to be three to six months
of expenses so that's not three to six
months of income that's three to six
months of expenses and once you do that
i want you to start investing 15 of your
income into retirement you're 20 years
old so you've got a good 40 50 years to
invest you're going to be a
multi-millionaire uh without question so
i want you to know that you're in a
great spot but i do want you to get rid
of that lease as soon as possible so
that all of this amazing income coming
from this business can help you get
through the baby steps and help you
accomplish your goals the other thing
alexis and i'm not against nice cars at
all but you don't need a car that that
expensive on your income you don't that
that's way too much car for your income
you're doing well but that's just too
much car that's just crazy too much car
so so we're gonna get rid of that get
something more reasonable you can pay
for it in cash you'll be getting your
emergency fund going uh stay on the line
we will give you the total money
makeover which is basically this is a
quick read alexis like i read it in two
hours but it walks you through our baby
steps in detail and it's gonna really
dive into baby step one why you need a
thousand dollars set aside baby step two
why we don't want debt baby step three
why we need three to six months of
expenses and it even talks about why
leasing a car is the most expensive way
to own a car just so you really get that
in your head in your heart of why we're
telling you to do this and you're gonna
go about this a different way with
having a car you pay for in cash that is
a smaller percentage of your annual
income than what you've got right now
you're you've really done fantastic
and as a matter of fact uh in addition
to total money makeover you are a
businesswoman and so i'll have kelly
give you a ticket to our business
boutique conference it's coming up
october 14th through the 16th you can
join us here in nashville
alexis if you want to if not you can
join us on live stream uh and that will
just give you even more motivation to
build this business you have done so
well
with no plan i'm kind of amazed at how
well you've done with no plan but you
need a plan for your money and you need
to plan for your business and when you
have that you are going to be
unstoppable woman like you're going to
be unstoppable when you start having
some intentionality some focus
some boundaries around what your goals
are and what you're trying to do you're
gonna you're gonna be incredible you
know one of the things i think that is
is hard george is sometimes
what makes us successful
being scrappy flying by the seat of our
pants
can be the actual thing that holds us
back to get to the next level and that's
true in money it's definitely true in
business i see this so much with with
women that i work with in business where
they are
super scrappy when they start out
but then they just stay scrappy and at a
point where they cannot grow and scale
because they aren't willing to get a
little more sophisticated they're not
willing to get systems and processes and
procedures and plans and all that in
place that you need to grow that you
need to scale and i think that um that's
one thing i love about the baby steps is
it is so simple tactical and
straightforward of you do this first you
do the second you do this third and so
on and i know you teach people you're so
great at breaking things down to very
actionable steps because the the truth
is when you can see it you can do it
when you have a plan and you know the
steps you can follow them yeah it
doesn't have to be complicated and i
think with all the voices out there
people kind of start to it starts to get
muddy and you i don't know what to do so
i'm just kind of kind of do my own thing
without really much of a plan and uh
alexis has done really well without that
but once she has this plan i'm scared
yeah i mean nothing's gonna stop her 20
years old she's crushing it in business
and i hope she can at least attend the
business boutique livestream because i'm
a huge fan of business boutique
i've been to many of these events back
in the day you marketed this event
people don't know that no that i was on
the business boutique team and i was i
was a card-carrying member and let me
tell you the estrogen in that room i got
fired up i was like maybe i need to
start a business i don't know christy
i'm i'm starting to have thoughts
so i just love this event and i love how
you are empowering so many women to take
control not only of their money but of
their business and entrepreneurial life
and giving them that amazing uh
steps that forward thinking purpose to
go you know what what got me here is not
going to get me there well i don't care
who you are and i don't care how
successful you are in is in business by
making it up as you go
everyone
will be more successful if they have a
plan everyone will make more progress
financially if you have a budget
everyone
will make more progress in any area of
your life whether it's your marriage
with your parenting with your business
your money doesn't matter
you're going to go further faster when
you have a plan zig ziglar says if you
aim for nothing you will hit it every
time we want you to aim for something we
want you to know what your finish line
is
so that you can cross it
this is the ranksy show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day is ecclesiastes
3 1 and 2. there is a time for
everything and a season for every
activity under the heavens a time to be
born and a time to die a time to plant
and a time to uproot
ralph waldo emerson said no change of
circumstances can repair a defect of
character well that's the truth you know
i love ecclesiastes george i actually
talk about this um in my book because i
think that we don't talk about seasons
enough the seasons of life and how the
season that we're in will often
determine what's important to us what
matters to us so what we spend our time
on will look different in one season
versus another would our version of life
balance will look different in one
season versus another another for some
of you all that are in baby step two
right now
your gazelle intense you're hustling
you're sacrificing beans and rice rice
and beans
that's right right now
i just want to say that again that's
right right now when you do the right
things at the right time you will feel
that sense of balance that you've been
looking for but it's not because you're
doing everything all the time it's
because you're doing the right things
and giving yourself permission to focus
on them
when they're right
and then when you're in baby step three
your baby steps seven
what's right looks a lot different and
that is a good thing so i actually uh
talk about that in my book take back
your time doing the right things at the
right time will lead to that sense of
balance you've been looking for
and uh and it's just it that comes the
heart of that comes from ecclesiastes
there's a time so freeing when you
realize that because you realize this
isn't forever this is a right now and
this thing doesn't define me yes this
season that i'm in this isn't going to
be my new life
and it kind of makes you go i don't need
to have that fomo anymore because right
now this is what i'm supposed to be
doing yes and next week i might be doing
this over here and you're in that season
now with this new book yes and it's so
it's so interesting too because uh we
were just telling you guys earlier if
you buy a copy of take back your time
today you get a copy of my devotional
free an e-copy of my devotional but one
of the i talk about this idea of seasons
in the devotional one of the things that
i've noticed in my life george is if i'm
not careful i can
look around me to the season that i'm in
and draw conclusions about my identity
based on my season so let me give you an
example
my house isn't always as clean as i
would like it to be i have three kids
under age six like no matter how much i
clean they're faster and messing up but
if i'm not careful i look around me and
i go oh my house is a mess i'm a mess
no no no i have little kids that make a
mess nothing personal carter and conley
who are in the lobby right now
i am not a mess i have little kids that
make a mess i am not a mess and so
there's something powerful and
separating yourself from your season but
we do need to consider it because it's
going to affect what our version of
balance looks like it's going to affect
what we need to and want to spend our
time on and
and that changes our perspective when we
set our priorities when we consider our
season so it's a great verse i love
ecclesiastes 3.
all right let's go to seattle washington
with nancy hey nancy how are you
uh i'm all right i wish
ken coleman was there too
you guys were at threesome i'm gonna
tell him that because ken coleman was
with me last week and we and someone
called nancy someone called um elmer
called and he said i wish it was dave
and i was like man we don't have the
right people in the right days
ken's gonna be so happy that he was
wanted though nancy i'm gonna tell him
yeah no but i'm glad that that the both
of you are there but
um i feel like i have
lost my mojo at work and
i'm like
about 308 days until i retire and it's
just kind of like
the last couple of years has just been
really
bad with work in terms of pandemic we've
had lots of staff
ill we've had a lot of patients ill
we've had
um
short staffing we've had to change on a
dime
notice to
do things differently
i'm just burned out and this is kind of
like all i can think about is
i want to get out of here yeah
what do you do
i work with psychiatric patients
okay
and so it's really a tough clientele to
work with and
it's
inpatient setting
and it's it's just been really really
really really really tough and it's just
kind of like
i
you know and i've always worked i've
done i've i love i've loved the work my
whole career i've been doing it for a
long time
and i
it is and i've always
really
been
able to tend to detail with work
in terms of all the
you know charting and assessments and
anything and everything all the details
i've always been you know on top of
everything and
i just kind of like you know i i
don't
care two cents right at this there's
times when there i don't care two cents
about it so it's just kind of like
well let me just kind of like i
feel like i'm putting my time in yeah
well i hear that i hear it in your voice
and it's and it's clear from your
perspective of your experience of this
but let me ask you this are you going to
stay with it
until you retire
well
i i could quit and have no income until
until i'm oh i have to be 62 to draw
retirement
or i could work until i'm 62 and then
get my return my my pension
or i could go and get another job
elsewhere i mean i believe me i've
thought about it and in fact i've been
hit about 14 months ago i got head
hunted by another facility in in the
region
and i
got a
interview set up
and
i mean they found me on linkedin
and
i got this close to going through with
it and decided you know what
i transferred i transferred to this
other
facility this other system
i go from being top of the heap in terms
of seniority to bottom of the heap and
this was still deep in the throes of the
pandemic and we got hit
our state got hit really bad with um
with kovid in you know the
march through
mid-summer-ish with that with that big
wave last year and i figured you know
what i i transferred facilities in june
and i could
you know be the first one cut if that
that's a new new place you know
hired me you know right so i pulled
myself out of the job interview yeah and
i didn't go through with the collector
you know i'm going to stay where i'm at
and and i'm
higher in seniority at the place where
i'm working and so
i mean i've i mean i've thought about
that i thought you might suggest that
well the the no no i just the reason i
wanted to ask is because if you've made
up your mind to leave then that's
different than if you've made up your
mind to stay and you're just asking how
to stay motivated while staying
well i i think basically you know i'm
i've
kind of the decision i've come
at is
i'm going to stay until i'm 62 and then
exit stage left afterwards so it's just
maybe basically
getting myself to
that and end point in
you know 308 days yeah okay here's so
nancy that's the reason i wanted to boil
it down to that of like you've
determined to stay because i did hear
that as unhappy as you are as burned out
as you are as overt as you are as
counting the days as you are you're
actually committed to stay and i and i
agree with that you're so close to
retirement if you had five years left
this would be a different conversation
you're so close it is it is i think it's
wise to say the financial aspect of it
but even the security aspect you're
talking about
here's the thing that i need to that i
want to help you with because this is
really your question your question is
not a career question your question is
not even a financial question it's
really a motivation question
so
if you've decided to stay
then you have a choice
you can stay and allow yourself to be
miserable
or you can stay and make the best of it
and as as
cheesy as this may sound
you've got to commit to make the best of
it because if not then you've decided to
stay and have chosen to be miserable
because you're playing the victim in a
choice you made you decide to stay so if
i were you and i was going to decide to
stay
i would just make the absolute best of
it that means thinking about everything
you're grateful for thinking about
everything that you love about it think
about everything that's positive making
sure you're getting filled up by
podcasts teachers things that bring you
joy things that give you energy outside
whether that's a a pastor or a scripture
or a church i'll if you'll stay on the
line i'll have kelly send you a copy of
my devotional to just encourage you in
this season just like we were just
saying george your season is where you
are not who you are you're in a tough
season but it doesn't mean that you're a
failure you're ending this on a bad note
you're
burnt out no no you're just in a tough
season
and you're gonna make the best of it
while you're there and nancy i believe
if you do everything you can to fill
yourself up while you're there the the
less you can talk about how bad it is
and the more you can focus on how good
it is it will actually change your
experience of it it's not cheesy it's
psychology and it works
act the way you want to feel and the
feelings will follow watch how that
makes a difference i hope that helps
george great job today thanks for
hanging out i want to thank our producer
ben hill associate producer kelly daniel
and you america for listening in
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs a producer of the
ramsey show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
send clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you